oh hello testing first I want to learn
for my microphone is I'm not talking to
my actual I am I'm talking to my friend
just my shirt
welcome to ask IJ time for another
fun-filled ask IJ episode with questions
taken from Facebook first of his Alex
who's asking you my favourite black ops
2 Matt is my favorite non DLC black ops
2 map would have to be raised a really
love that cuz I just love nating from
across the map right into the center and
almost hitting somebody every single
time who gets under your skin more
joffrey from guy oh yeah I'm not gonna
read the rest of us because Joffrey
drives me absolutely nuts like I have
never wanted to physically go in to a
television and hurt another human being
like I want to hurt this Karen every
time you thing on a screen is gonna take
a little scrawny face and all slaps
glass what hey where's DJ no I don't
know I lost her somewhere she's
somewhere so I don't think I'll ever be
able to have a child because I'm feeling
you'd probably lose it
that's not funny dance without stopping
for three days or what I eat moldy
cheese or forties I don't like either
one of those I don't I don't these are
hypothetical situations that I never
want to be placed in next question
Charlotte team Damon or no team Damon
I'm team Bank team Damon all the way
across the sky hey Quinn wants to know
why I've started making YouTube videos
in the first place on YouTube to be
completely honest with you just sort of
happened I really liked making videos
and I like making people laugh so I just
started kind of posting stuff and people
started watching and people started
laughing and I started posting more and
here we are today six or seven years
later crazy one thing that I have found
is since I now put most of my energy
into making videos and being outgoing
online that my personal life real
Justine has calmed down so much I
remember I used to be so crazy so loud
and now if I'm not making your video I'm
just kind of chill I'm just sitting
there cuz I just expelled so much energy
for you guys
no honey left real world real world
someone tells you that you will die
tomorrow
morbid question moving on Twitter or
Facebook
ah well is that just these questions
from Facebook oh definitely Facebook but
in all seriousness Twitter if I could
play the instrument what would it be oh
you know I I would love to play the
piano like I just think people play the
piano it's just so elegant it's great I
can't do it can't do it I can't play
twinkle twinkle little star maybe even
mary had a little lamb but that's
getting a little crazy have I ever
wanted to cut off all of my hair one and
pony Oh raw here'll going to shave it
all off one day one day not yet will let
me go draw my life video yes I will be
making a draw my life don't work calm
down I'm working on it I have it half
written I bought the paper to draw on
the work one step in the right direction
what would you do if there's a zombie
apocalypse and you didn't have any
weapons huh well Kristina Rodriguez I
would go get some weapons I would make
some weapons trust me I would find a way
or I'd find some friends that have
weapons and be their friends what do I
think of the new map pack for black ops
2 I absolutely love it - Conan it thank
you for asking
are you going to do a Furby inspired
makeup tutorials J that's a great idea
let me work on that one oh that's all
the questions I have like you guys for
watching this episode of ask i J I'm
gonna take next week's questions from
YouTube so leave me some comments with
your questions don't forget to like
don't forget to subscribe and I will see
you guys whenever I see you
oh you are not a gentleman you're
humping Street cones